BEFORE.
ISLANDERS WIN IN OVERTIME LAST .
GOOD PLAY BY
BARZAL GOT AWAY PROSFROM STILLM.
TO THE INTERIOR
DeBRINCAT.
DOWN WENT SEASON.
KANE SLIDES IT DOWN.
STROME BACK FOR KANE.
NOW TOEAVING
STROME ALONE.
HE'S NOT THE BOARDS.
DeBRINCAT, THAT TIME HE SCORES.
DeBRINCAT WITH A ONE-TIMER WITG.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU'RE
KIEFER BELLOWS SENDS THIS
PALMIERI.
PELECH, FACE-OFF WIN F FIT.
HE'LL FORCE IT DEEP.
>> A.J.: BARRY TROTZ UTILIZING
THIS LINE A LITTLE MORE  BREAKO
THE WALL TO SET UP THIS ZONE
POSSESSION TIME.
HE GET HE LIKES -- HE PUTBACKBO
OFF THE BACK OF THE NET.
DACH MOVES IT.
BAILEY USING HIS SKATE TO CORRAL
IT.
WE HEARD SHANNON AND ANSONOR AH.
39 SECONDS TO GO ON THE KILL.
KAAW ALL THE PUCKS.
THIS MOVEMENT, HIGH TONFLICTED.
ANDERS LEE, JUST WIDE.
A CHANCE FOR PELECH BEHIND --
FAR POST.
AND JOSH BAILEY ISO DeBRINCAT,
AND STROME SCORESSHIFT.
THE LAST LINE THAT WAS OUT
HERE IS DeBRINCAT.
AHO TRYING TO CATCH HIM.
DeBRINCAT TO THE BACKHAND.
MUCH PUCK MOVEMENT, WANTED TO T.
LOOK AT THAT LEE
SCORED ONE AT 19:58 IN THE THIRD
.
HE DID NOT SC OF
FLEURY. ISLANDERS.
CHICAGO HAS WON THE PREVIOU.
>> Brendan: MATHEW BARZAL UP
NEXTND.
>> A.J.: QUICK MOVE BY MATHEW
BARZAL
BAGS OF TRICK IN THE NHL,
PATRICK KANE IN  THE TRIGGER OV
GLOVE.
>> A.J.: IT'S UNREAL WHEN YOU
WATCH THIS GUY.
COMES IN WITH